esta vez nos piden encontrar la elipse
que está representada por la ecuación x
4 al cuadrado sobre 16 más que menos 1
al cuadrado sobre 49 igual a 1
y nos dan un montón de opciones tenemos
todas estas opciones de hecho son cuatro
y vamos a ver cuál de ellas es la opción
correcta primero sabemos que el centro
de la elipse será el punto 4,1 y cómo es
que lo sabemos bueno es que la ecuación
de la elipse es de la forma x menos la
coordenada x del centro de la elipse
esto elevado al cuadrado entre el radio
horizontal elevado al cuadrado más
james menos la coordenada james del
centro de la elipse esto elevado al
cuadrado entre el radio vertical elevado
al cuadrado igual a 1 por lo tanto el
centro de la elipse está en 41 y por lo
tanto ésta no va a ser mi opción
correcta porque el centro no está en 4,1
aquí bueno tampoco tengo el centro en
4.1 aquí tampoco y bueno aquí sí está
así
la única opción que tiene como centro al
punto 4,1 así que ya podemos asegurar
que esta es la opción correcta esto
inclusive sin averiguar lo demás es
decir cuánto vale el radio horizontal y
cuánto vale el radio vertical pero vamos
a verificarlo de todas formas así que
observa el radio horizontal va a ser de
bueno 1 2 3 4 es esta línea que tengo de
color rosa tiene una longitud de 4 y si
nos fijamos aquí en la ecuación justo
por aquí la ecuación nos dice que
necesitamos un radio horizontal de 4
porque la raíz de 16 es 4 y bueno
podemos pensar que aquí abajo tenemos el
radio horizontal elevado al cuadrado que
es 4 elevado al cuadrado
y bueno si vemos el radio vertical por
aquí te puedes dar cuenta que tiene una
longitud de 7 vamos desde igual a 1
hasta allí igual a 8 tenemos una
longitud de 7
en mi ecuación si subo para camps
podemos ver que en efecto 7 elevado al
cuadrado es 49 aquí tengo el radio
vertical elevado al cuadrado
así que ya están ahora si podemos
asegurar que mi opción correcta es la
opción de bastante fácil y bastante
sencillo y hemos acabado